well good evening London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensor when I launched
this show I promised to cancel our
Insidious cancel Culture The Usual
Suspects sneered Castle culture is fake
they said there's nothing whatsoever to
do with the real world it's a populist
argument I see and hear it every day
canceled culture is not real said Time
Magazine CNN thinks it's time to cancel
this talk of canceled culture the new
Statesman rafts that canceled culture
does not exist but it does exist apart
for anything else I wouldn't be doing
this show if Castle culture didn't exist
it's everywhere it's the creeping fear
now stalking all of us that we're only
wherever one mistake away or a perceived
mistake away from a scandal that can end
your career I think that you rub
whatever it's coming up late for the
show early today he described it
perfectly
nowadays I'm absolutely terrified every
time I have to do an interview I come
out in hives and I never ever dare read
them because it's so scary you know you
can't really you have to be so careful
what you say
um you can't really uh just chat and and
have a lively discussion with someone
you always have to watch what you're
saying and I find that very uh it's very
alien to me because I've spent my life
really I'm having a lovely time with
journalists and chatting about
everything and now that's that's uh
that's a little more complicated
how sad how pathetic frankly the society
has taken this turn and it's no longer
just celebrities or public figures you
need to be afraid take Colonel Kelvin
Wright who's a bit of a British hero as
a reservist army medic he ran the
emergency department a camp Bastion in
Afghanistan he flew in Chinook
helicopters across Enemy Lines to rescue
soldiers and civilians suffering the
gruesome injuries of War he saved many
many lives over 14 years of service but
then Colonel Kelvin got canceled forced
out of the British army his crime it was
to share a social media post by a
woman's rights campaigner called Helen
Joyce and all it said was if women
cannot stand in a public place and say
men cannot be women then we do not have
women's rights at all you might agree
with that statement you might not agree
with it but last time I checked in a
Democratic Society you're entitled to
your opinion
and regardless it wasn't his comment in
the first place he just shared it
but a formal complaint was of course
made LGBT activists dragged a colonel
into a disciplinary process a seven page
letter signed by these activists and is
supposedly anti-trans views you hadn't
expressed any anti-trans views had no
place in the military
so he walked away
the biggest misunderstanding about
cancer culture is it has to involve a
celebrity being expunged from public
life and there are many examples of that
happening but the reality is we're now
so used to righteous mobs throwing
Tantrums about other people's opinions
that every everybody is at risk
employers are so afraid of being shamed
for being on the wrong side of a tribal
argument they'll gladly hang you out to
dry sooner than take any risk was the
damage already done it's been revealed
this week the colonel Kelvin Wright has
now been cleared of any wrongdoing by an
official inquiry but his army career is
over forced out by virtue signaling busy
bodies with nothing better to do and
certainly people who never did what he
did in a war zone serving his country
it's a disgrace
what I'm joined Now by Colonel Dr Kelvin
Wright well great to have you Colonel I
I really you know I come from a family
with lots of military my brother retired
as a colonel after 37 years recently and
when I mentioned your story to him and
told him what you've done in Afghanistan
he said that was pretty hardcore Duty
flying in on those helicopters to go and
rescue people who'd been severely
wounded so thank you first of all for
your service to your country I don't
know how many times you've been told
that in recent months but it's suspect
not enough right interest enough in
recent months quite a few times I mean I
I joined at the height of Afghanistan my
my mission was to go and practice
medicine in a war zone I felt as a
consultant in a background of emergency
medicine and intensive care I had
something to offer and I was working in
hospital at the time where a lot of my
trainees were military and I felt it was
time for me to do my bit so it was it's
one of the proudest times and there's no
way that I'm going to let these events
overshadow what I say is the proudest
medicine I've probably ever done in my
time the most inexplicable part of your
story is not that a bunch of lgbtq 2
plus a name gets longer by the minute
um that these activists tried to cancel
you over reposting a quote which many
would agree with certainly from a
biological sex point of view
the most scandalous part of this is that
the Army went along with this launched a
formal investigation into you you know
told you it was specifically about the
fact you'd shared this post this other
person's opinion you had shared it that
seems to me extraordinary that the
British army would do this to somebody
like you well I mean there's two
interesting points that you you allude
to there actually the first is of course
yesterday happened
um and when this first started and I'm I
am so grateful to the help that I've had
from the Free Speech Union
um at a really trying time
um the the advice from them and having
someone on the end of a phone you can
just say actually you're okay that's
what you should be doing was phenomenal
but this process I I said the early
stages it makes you wonder who is
running the Army is it the chief of the
general staff or is it Stonewall this
this gender ideology and this fear of um
just common debate amongst professionals
is absolute drowning out our major
institutions I mean the irony is that
people like you have served their
country to safeguard free speech and
freedoms well I agree I mean every year
so I've been a combining officer it's a
great privilege for the last five years
um two as a half kernel and three is a
full kernel and um every year as a
commanding officer we would stand in
front of our troops and we would talk
about the values and standards of the
army moral courage those people moral
courage doing the right thing even when
sometimes it's difficult around you and
that's what really gets me a little bit
on this why did someone else hire up the
chain not have the moral courage to say
actually most of this complaint is
absolutely vexatious the person
complained that two or three years ago I
wouldn't let them wear their pronouns on
their uniform the Army has a uniform
policy that's not me there's a uniform
policy they complained that two years
ago my wife who'd actually come to do
casualty makeup for us at an exercise
stated she'd like to see a man and a
woman dancing on Strictly Come Dancing
in the ballroom section and apparently
that shows poor family values on my part
and then there was this complaint and
those three elements the key parts of of
the complaint and then there was this
quote um which I I so it was actually
even more ridiculous than we realized it
was absolutely laughable and the fact
that no one had the moral courage to say
you know Moses is rubbish they should
not get to um a full colonally being
investigated it should not get to
someone being driven out someone fearing
for their civilian occupation because
this is the problem this kind of stuff
overreaches into others more positive
point for you when you said I'm done
with this uh literally very early on um
I received a phone call and I remember
the words exactly it was you're in a lot
of trouble
this has gone all the way to the top
um the complainant is very well
connected in the diversity Network
and from that minute I just felt there
was no chance of getting a fair hearing
you you just think actually and you're
going to be investigating but within
that process I was never alone were you
being investigated really for I don't
know so that's the interesting point I
was never shown the complaint until
after the verdict was in so I had to
make a statement
on a complaint of which I had never even
seen which is ridiculous so this seven
pages the first I saw this seven pages
was after the process was over did the
seven pages make any record of your wall
record no I mean no it was the the three
key points I've talked about already and
there there's just other it was people
just throwing mud hoping something with
oh one person throwing mud hoping
something would stop are you are you
transphobic do you have a problem with
transgender people not at all
um I mean as a doctor I just treat
everyone as I find them and and as they
treat me as a human being I treat
everyone as they treat me
um as a combining officer I'm more
interested in someone's professional
skills my patients have never said to me
excuse me are you LGBT no uh doctor
they're just one are you a doctor are
you good at your job and that's all I'm
interested absolutely not is society
just going slightly mad with this gender
ideology stuff it does feel that way I
mean when we we've lost the concept of
reason debate we've lost the concept as
you said the olumbi stands for free
speech and and the fact that many men
and women over the years have paid a
really high price for the privilege of
someone's having uh the right to to
speak yes and now we are trampling all
over that so yes I do think Society is
going absolutely crazy you had to leave
a job that you loved and you've gone
back to the NHS you're now working in
another hospital in Mansfield and
Nottinghamshire
um how do you feel that your army career
was brought to an end like this
well as I said I'm just chatting I I'm
not going to let these events sell what
I thought were 14 really fabulous years
I met so many really good soldiers
Sailors air crew during my time
um I taught on trauma courses it was an
absolute privilege to do that with uh
with the with young soldiers
particularly
um it was a privilege to serve and treat
those patients when they're having a
really bad day so there's no way I'm
going to let this spoil all of that good
stuff but it does leave a rather sour
taste that after 14 years honorable
service it's brought to a rather
premature end in the in the the finding
which cleared you any wrongdoing the
final report said that your Facebook
post was clearly not unlawful or duh
although some would find it disagreeable
and now when I read that I was like well
maybe they would but so what well so
what in a Democratic Society I find lots
of things disagreeable I don't want
people to lose their jobs over it
absolutely and in a Democratic Society
we have the right to have two people
having a a heated debate but at the end
of the day those opinions can can be
held but for me the crucial thing and
one of the things I'm really Keen to
this kind of conversation is a precedent
has been set now the Army has been
forced to say actually we do have a
responsibility on the public sector
quality Duty the force data ruling uh is
interpreted legally it's not interpreted
how the gender Champions might like it
interpreted it's written down in law how
it's interpreted and we've got that
established so future younger soldiers
Sailors air crew and there are multiple
cases of this already going on the Free
Speech Union we've got other cases of
service Personnel who fall into this
trap as well a precedent has been set
which hopefully will protect some of
them in the future Colonel thank you
very much indeed for coming in uh you're
a war hero you're a British hero what
happened to you is a total disgrace and
I'm extremely glad you've now been uh
cleared of any wrongdoing you should
never have been being taken through this
process and the Army's loss is the nhs's
gain and I wish you all the very best
for the future thank you it's been an
absolute pleasure thank you for having
me
what a story what a disgrace how has our
country come to this I mean seriously